l'irlande est un pays qui a énormément
profité de son adhésion à l'union
européenne où la communauté européenne
dans son temps 73 et le tapis qui vit
avec des règles financières qui sont
peut-être pas totalement celle de
l'esprit européen
mais si règles financières ont permis de
créer un pays relativement riche mais où
il ya également des inégalités sociales
c'est à dire que la rue church
irlandaise ne profite pas à tout le
monde
sur le deuxième point la question
fondamentale c'est le lien avec
l'irlande du nord
et je vous rappelle à cette occasion
en l'occurrence que les rangs du nord
est l'un des pays où l'une des régions
du royaume uni qui avaient des comptes
l'objectif
exactement comme les cos et donc le
chine fans va être s'ils gagnent une
force extrêmement important dans le
processus non seulement irlandais mais
également dans le processus break site à
savoir quand on connaît l'importance
qu'on lui déjà les négociations sur la
question de la frontière langdell on
peut en effet dire que la victoire du
fils feng va être un élément
supplémentaire dans le cadre des
négociations à venir entre le royaume
uni et l'union européenne